DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE"."
IT’S A LONG WAY FROM THE ALAMO
BOOKED AN L.A. RESTAURANT OWNER,
ANGELA, CALLED ON HER CITY’S
MAYOR FOR SHUTTING DOWN HER
OUTDOOR BUSINESS WHILE ALLOWING
A HOLLYWOOD MOVIE CREW TO SET UP
A SIMILAR DAILY AREA YARDS AWAY.
>> I’M LOSING EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING I OWN IS BEING TAKEN
AWAY FROM ME AND THEY HAVE SET
UP A MOVIE COMPANY RIGHT NEXT TO
MY OUTDOOR PATIO.
THEY HAVE NOT GIVEN US MONEY
THEY HAVE SHUT US DOWN.
WE CANNOT SURVIVE.
MY STAFF CANNOT SURVIVE.
TELL ME THAT THIS IS DANGEROUS!
BUT RIGHT NEXT TO ME IS A SLAP
IN MY FACE, 50 FEET AWAY.
MAYOR GARCETTI AND GAVIN NEWSOM
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT DOESN’T HAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT, THAT DOES NOT HAVE
A JOB, AND ALL THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE GOING UNDER AND WE NEED
YOUR HELP!
WE NEED SOMEBODY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
>> Greg: IF SHE WERE A FAMOUS
ACTRESS, SHE’D BE WORKING.
SHE’S NOT, SO L.A.’s NANNIES
CLOSED HER DOWN.
ERIC GARCETTI SAYS HIS HEART
GOES OUT TO HER BUT NOT ON A
PLATE BECAUSE RESTRICTIONS ARE
NECESSARY UNLESS YOU’RE A
HOLLYWOOD FILM CREW.
IN THE LAND OF DEMS ONLY THE
RICH AND POWERFUL THRIVE.
THE LITTLE PEOPLE GET CRUSHED.
YOU KNOW HOLLYWOOD WILL THANK
GARCETTI.
MAYBE ON THE POOP ENCRUSTED
SIDEWALK.
WHEN BAD STUFF HAPPENS YOU’RE
ALWAYS FIRST IN LINE FOR RELIEF
OR EXEMPTION.
ON "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" PETE
DAVIDSON SAID THIS ABOUT THE
STATEN ISLAND PROTESTERS.
>> THE RULE IS THAT THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO LET PEOPLE EAT OR
DRINK OUTSIDE AND THE OWNER SAID
NO ONE WANTS TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THEY’LL GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
THE ARGUMENT THAT PEOPLE IN
STATEN ISLAND DON’T WANT TO
DRINK OUTSIDE CAN BE DISPROVEN
BY GOING TO LITERALLY ANY
LITTLE LEAGUE GAME.
>> THEY ARE MAKING US LOOK LIKE
BABIES.
>> Greg: HE SAID ALL THAT
BEFORE A LIVE STUDIO AUDIENCE
HOW HE’S DOING EXACTLY WHAT
THOSE PROTESTERS WANTED TO DO.
WORK.
HOW DID PETE GET AROUND THOSE
RESTRICTIONS TO MOCK THOSE WHO
COULDN’T?
"SNL" PAID AUDIENCE MEMBERS 150
BUCKS A HEAD TO SHOW UP, MAKING
THEM HIRED EXTRAS.
IF ONLY A RESTAURANT COULD DO
THAT.
THEY CAN’T.
MEANWHILE, THE BUTT OF MANY
ELITIST JOKES, GUY FIERI, IS
DOING MORE.
HE RAISED 21 MILLION BUCKS FOR
43,000 WORKERS.
IN RESPONSE TO THOSE RESTAURANT
CRITICS WHO LOVE PADDLING PILING
NARROW FLAVOR TIME.
AS ONE MAYOR DESTROYS SMALL
BUSINESSES WHILE PLAYING
FAVORITES TO THE RICH AND FAMOUS
A FOODIE HELPS A LITTLE GUY OR
RATHER THOUSANDS OF THEM.
HOLLYWOOD SHOULD MAKE A MOVIE
ABOUT THAT.
THEY WON’T.
SO I WANT TO PLAY THE SOUND ON
TAPE FROM ADMIRAL GIROIR.
>> WHAT REALLY BREAKS MY HEART
IS I DON’T KNOW OF ANY DATA THAT
SAYS YOU NEED TO SHUT DOWN
OUTDOOR DINING OR OUTDOOR BARS.
WE REALLY WANTED TO LIMIT THE
INDOOR CROWDED PLACES.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO DO WHAT’S
NECESSARY TO TURN THE PANDEMIC
BUT NOT MORE.
IT’S NOT EVIDENCE-BASED.
>> Greg: WHY DO POLITICIANS
ADHERE TO THIS IDEA OF THERE’S
NO DATA BEHIND IT?
>> Dagen: THEY DON’T HAVE THE
DATA, CONTACT TRACING IS FOR
CRAP AND THEY ARE IGNORANT AND
ARROGANT AND INCOMPETENT AND
WON’T ADMIT BACK TO THE PEOPLE
THEY GOVERN.
THESE BUSINESS OWNERS, THESE
RESTAURANT OWNERS, THEY BUILT
THESE DREAMS JUST BASED ON HARD
WORK AND DETERMINATION IN THAT
HARD WORK AND DETERMINATION
CAN’T SAVE THEM FROM THE HANDS
OF THESE POLITICIANS.
POLITICIANS HAVE ALWAYS SAID,
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE HEART
AND SOUL OF AMERICA.
THEY DON’T HAVE HEARTS AND
SOULS.
HOW IN THE HELL DO THEY EVEN
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
I WAS RAISE THE CHILD OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
MY PARENTS RAN A SMALL GROCERY
IN THE SOUTH.
IN THE RURAL SOUTH, AND THEY
ALWAYS KNEW BECAUSE OF THEIR
SIZE THAT POLITICIANS DIDN’T
GIVE A COLD DAMN IN HELL ABOUT
THEM BECAUSE THEY WEREN’T LINING
THEIR POCKETS.
THE BIG DOT GAINOR MISSING THE
SMALL GOT TRAMPLED ON.
MY MOTHER KNEW THAT IT TOOK SO
EITHER SMALL BUSINESSES TO TRY
TO SAVE THEIR OWN AND RIGHT
BEFORE SHE DIED SHE SAID I WISH
I WAS RICH SO I COULD GIVE IT
ALL AWAY.
ANYBODY WHO HAS THE JOB WHO
HASN’T MISSED A PAYCHECK THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE ALL DOING.
MEANTIME THESE POLITICIANS NEED
TO GET THERE ASSES FIRED.
>> Greg: IT’S A PRETTY GREAT
IDEA, 150 BUCKS I HAD TO WATCH A
SHOW.
YOU GET AROUND THE REGULATIONS
BY HIRING THEM AS EXTRAS.
PRETTY SNEAKY.
>> Dana: IMAGINE IF THE BAR IN
STATEN ISLAND HAD ENOUGH CASH ON
HAND TO PAY ITS CUSTOMERS TO
COME INTO THE BAR.
THEN I GUESS THEY COULD ALSO GET
AROUND THE RESTRICTIONS SOMEHOW?
I IMAGINE.
IT’S INTERESTING.
ADMIRAL GIROIR SAYS HIS HEART IS
BREAKING.
ANGELA MARSTON’S HEART IS
OBVIOUSLY BROKEN AND 9 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE WATCHED IT.
ERIC GARCETTI SAYS HIS HEART IS
BROKEN.
IF EVERYONE HAS BROKEN HEARTS,
AMERICANS, I KNOW WE’LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW TO HELP
MAKE IT COME FROM THE GOVERNMENT
BUT I DO FEEL LIKE SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING, GREG.
THIS PANDEMIC IS EXPOSING
GOVERNMENT TO A WHOLE GENERATION
OF YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS WHO,
MAYBE THEY HAVE BIG HEARTS BUT
THEY WILL REALIZE THAT A
CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINT ON
SMALLER GOVERNMENT IS THE WAY TO
PRESERVE LIBERTY AND THEIR
ABILITY TO MAKE A LIVING.
>> Greg: GERALDO, IT’S KIND OF
WEIRD TO SEE POLITICIANS
DECIDING WHO ARE NONESSENTIAL
WORKERS.
THERE IS A CERTAIN IRONY TO
THAT.
>> Geraldo: I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH DANA ABOUT THE NEED TO
RETHINK GOVERNMENTS RULE.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND I HAVE
TWO GRANDCHILDREN IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THEY HAD 25,000 CASES IN
CALIFORNIA YESTERDAY ALONE.
9,000 IN L.A. COUNTY.
AND GARCETTI, THIS IS THE LAND
OF THE FIRES AND THE EARTHQUAKES
SAID THAT THE COVID THING IS THE
GREATEST THREAT TO LIFE IN
LOS ANGELES THAT WE HAVE EVER
FACED.
I THINK YOU’VE GOT THIS VACCINE
COMING DOWN THE ROAD.
I FEEL FOR THESE PEOPLE.
MY DAD OWNED A COFFEE SHOP AND A
DINER THAT WENT BROKE RIGHT IN
BRIAN KILMEADE’S NEIGHBORHOOD IN
LONG ISLAND.
I GET IT.
I UNDERSTAND.
MY HEART BREAKS FOR ANGELA, ONE
OF THE MOST ARTICULATE
SPOKESPEOPLE AGAINST THE
CLUMSINESS OF BIG GOVERNMENT.
THE LOGIC OF IT AT TIMES.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THERE’S A
DESPERATION.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
ELECTED, THEY WANT TO SAVE
LIVES.
WE HAVE NEVER FACED THIS, NOT
SINCE 1918 HAPPILY FACED
SOMETHING WHERE YOU’VE GOT
PEOPLE DYING LEFT AND RIGHT
EVERY 30 SECONDS AND AMERICAN
DIES.
YOU’VE GOT TO GIVE THESE PEOPLE
A LITTLE SLACK.
YES THEY ARE INTRUDING ON
LIBERTARIAN VALUES AT ITS
BABBITT "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" IS
MOCKING THEM.
BUT GIVE ME A BREAK HERE.
>> Greg: JESSE, MY ISSUE IS
THEY ARE BEING MOCKED BY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO SKIN IN THE GAME.
WE CAN CRITICIZE ALL RESTAURANT
OWNERS BECAUSE WE GET TO SIT
HERE AND TALK ABOUT IT.
WE GET A PAYCHECK.
PETE DAVIDSON GETS A PAYCHECK.
HIS COMPANY PAID FOR HIS
AUDIENCE.
>> Jesse: ISN’T THAT HOW
PEOPLE GET PAID TO YOUR SHOW,
GUTFELD?
ISN’T THAT HOW YOU GOT AROUND
IT?
I AGREE WITH BOTH OF YOU AND
GERALDO.
IF "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" HAD
BEEN SHUT DOWN WHICH I THINK
DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE LOVED
BUT LET’S SAY THEY WERE SHUT
DOWN PERMANENTLY AND PETE
DAVIDSON WAS JUST STARTING OUT.
HE HAD TO SCRAPE BY, NO SALARY
AND WAS FORCED TO GO UNDERGROUND
TO DO HIS LITTLE SKITS IN FRONT
OF SMALL CLOUDS SO WE CAN MAKE
ENDS MEET AND THEN WAS ARRESTED
AND THROWN IN PRISON FOR JUST
BEING FUNNY, I WOULD’VE HAD HIS
BACK.
YOU WOULD’VE HAD HIS BACK.
STATEN ISLAND WOULD’VE HAD HIS
BACK.
THE SAME THING IS HAPPENING TO
PUB OWNERS AND HE DOESN’T HAVE
THEIR BACK.
HER -- TO GERALDO’S POINT, YOU
CAN PROTECT THE SICK WE ALSO
HAVE TO PROTECT THE HEALTHY.
RIGHT NOW YOU’RE HAVING
POLITICIANS BASICALLY CREATE A
COVID CASTE SYSTEM WHERE SOME
PEOPLE ARE TREATED LIKE PEASANTS
AND THE REST ARE TREATED LIKE
ROYALTY.
IF YOU’RE AN ACTOR, YOU CAN EAT
OUTSIDE.
IF YOU’RE NOT AN ACTOR, YOU
CAN’T EAT OUTSIDE.
YOU CAN BUST DOWN A BUSINESSES
DOOR BUT YOU CAN’T OPEN THE
DOOR?
BLACK LIVES MATTER CAN PROTEST
VENTRAL PEOPLE CAN’T?
TO SAY YOU’RE DOING IT TO SAVE
LIVES, HOW MANY LIVES ARE THERE
ACTUALLY SAVING WITH THESE
RESTRICTIONS.
SEVEN ABOVE TOP TEN STATES WITH
THE HIGHEST DEATH TOLL ARE RUN
BY DEMOCRATS.
SO CALIFORNIA HAS DONE MULTIPLE
SHUTDOWNS, MULTIPLE MASS
MANDATES AND THEY ARE GOING WAY
UP.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO SHUT PEOPLE
DOWN AT LEAST PAY THEM THE CASH.
NANCY IS HOLDING BACK THE PURSE
STRINGS.
THEY ARE PLAYING WITH A TRILLION
.5.
YOU COULD PAY EACH RESTAURANT
OWNER $10,000 A MONTH TO CLOSE
DOORS AND DO TAKE-OUT BUT THEY
ARE SAYING NO YOU’RE GOING TO
SHUT DOWN.
YOU’REARE NOT GOING TO PAY YOU A
HAVE TO WATCH OVER PAY BRITO --
ACTOR EAT A BURRITO ACROSS THE
STREET.
OMAR’S HUSBAND GOT HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS IN BAILOUT
RELIEF AND HE DOESN’T RUN A
RESTAURANT.
HE RUNS A POLITICAL CONSULTING
FIRM.
HE APPLIED AND GOT THE MONEY BUT
THEY CAN’T GET THE MONEY AT A
RESTAURANT.
>> Dana: WOW.